And this answer is tricky. We will derive it through the truth table. Now there's eight possible cases.
Flip one can come of heads or tail; same for flip two, heads, tail, heads, tail;
and the same for flip three and if you look at this every possible combination is represented.
For example, these are heads, tail, tail.
Now each of those outcomes has the same probability of an eighth, because it's eight cases.
So 8 x 1/8 sums up to 1. In how many cases do we have exactly one H?
It turns out that it's true for only three cases.
The H could be in the first position, in the second position, or in the third position.
So three out of eight cases have a single H.
Each of those carries a probability so we sum those cases up to carry a total of 3/8 of a probability.
These are the same as 0.375.